the master verse has captured millions
of new guides you've fans and all of
them one more showdowns between gigantic
monsters since the next movie is
scheduled for 2020 and no trailers out
yet it has all but itched our minds even
more so to keep up the pace and
enthusiasm of this new extended universe
as fans of Godzilla and the new guy
juice we would like to dive into
something not asked before what if King
Ghidorah and muta prime were to fight
one another one of them are alpha
species but there are stark differences
between them
King Ghidorah comes from outer space and
has a characteristic of Total
Annihilation while muta prime only lives
to propagate the species being the most
evolved of the jinn Shenmue Shaye's and
the most powerful so to find out who
will win in a deadly fight between these
two Titans that were the arch rivals of
Godzilla and his species the only two
who were close to or even defeated the
Godzilla individual species at some
point of time to get to the answer of
this we need to recheck the profiles and
assess the strengths and weaknesses of
these two monsters let's start with the
lesser-known of the to the muta prime
also dubbed as Titanes gentian mushi she
was a giant parasitic dikaya that
appears in a 20-19 graphic novel
Godzilla aftershock the ancient Japanese
gave her the name Jin Jin mushi all the
earthquake beloved due to her ability to
create earthquakes and her beetle-like
appearance monarch names ammeter prime
due to her being larger and more
powerful than a regular Muto's the Miura
prime is nearly identical in appearance
to the regular female Muto except for
several notable differences the meter
Prime has a heart and outer shell with
razor-sharp back spires on it large
orange glowing four limbs as well as
several smaller pairs of four limbs on
her chest the species of muta is bigger
than a female muta and by the looks of
it in a graphic novel after shop she
seems to be at par with Godzilla in
height so let's assume that she stands
between 350 and 400 feet tall around the
Year 1100 BCE
muta Prime encounters a member of
Godzilla species and the two Titans
engage in a ferocious battle eventually
she gains the upper hand beating down
the Godzilla but not fully killing it
using her ovipositor as she inserts the
eggs into the stomach lining
of the wounded Godzilla in 2014 she
resurfaced after the events of Godzilla
killing the lesser murrow's and if you
several times in many locations around
the world until she nearly had Godzilla
for the count but was distracted by
humans long enough for Godzilla to turn
the tide of the battle and take the win
with the use of his atomic pulse it
seems so familiar and similar to the
fight between Godzilla and Ghidorah
where Godzilla was nearly killed by
Mazda zero until he was distracted by
the Orca device giving Godzilla enough
time to transform and take the win with
the use of his atomic pulse the Miura
prime possessed tremor inducing legs
making her capable of producing massive
earthquakes as explained by dr. Emma
Russel in the graphic novel the mera
prime triggers these massive earthquakes
into other junior art members of
Godzilla species into a fight they
cannot win to out her life muta Prime
has killed several Godzilla's no easy
feat for any Titan and successfully
planted her eggs inside their bodies she
was able to knock down Godzilla himself
on one hit the Miura prime can use a
powerful sonic roar able to shatter
Godzilla's dorsal plates the Miura
Prime's eyes will glow red when she uses
the sonic roar similar to how gods asked
eyes glow blue when he uses his atomic
breath a rivalry with the g-man mirrors
the one between calm and the skull
crawlers so going to the other corner we
have King Ghidorah
also dubbed as the false King or monster
zero or scientifically name as Titanes
Ghidorah this monster needs no
introduction as he is the most well
known of all the arch enemies of the big
G first appearing in 1964 the schedule
has appeared in several of Godzilla's
films and portrayed as the ultimate foe
of the big G and most of us remake adore
towers over all the other Titans
standing at five hundred feet tall and
weighing and more than 140,000 tons with
a wingspan that is easily more than
1,000 feet across but more than that is
outer space or alien biology give him
resilience and immunity to many of
humanity's weapons and even the attacks
of other Titans as evident during his
duels with Godzilla when he was seen
unscathed
even with Godzilla's powerful atomic
breath and ro Dan's fiery nature the
fact that he was unaffected by the
oxygen destroyer weapon that left
Godzilla almost sleeping with the fishes
literally and metaphorically shows that
his body is by far one of the most
durable and dense of all the Titans he
could also make water vapor heat up to
extreme levels and create localized
storm systems Ghidorah has the ability
to bite down onto power lines as well as
other tyrants and absorb the pout
himself significantly boosting his
strength Ghidorah could shoot golden
gravity beams from his mouth much like
how Godzilla draws up lights glow
whenever he is about to release his
atomic breath Ghidorah sprout glows the
same way before he filed his gravity
beams he was also able to regenerate one
of these three heads that were
decapitated by Godzilla almost
instantaneously so how do these two
masters compare against one another
well Ghidorah takes the cake for size
and weight regarding durability both
these Titans are nine indestructible
even brushing off Godzilla's atomic
breath but both were killed by the
atomic pulse but if we talk about ranged
attacks then this time the Miura Prime
takes the win with her sonic roar
powerful enough to shatter Godzilla's
dorsal plates a feat that not even the
most powerful gravity beams can do so
it's a one win for Ghidorah and one for
prime and a draw let's dive into the
other features that make this Titans
powerful and on top mera prime can
create tremors and earthquake with her
limbs while Ghidorah can create
localized storm systems both powers are
a show of force but knees I can deal any
damage to the other Ghidorah on the
other hand has amazing healing and
regeneration capabilities which might
take this monster a 1-up over the prime
which means that any damage done by the
Muto can be healed almost near
instantaneously
Emira prime however has another trick up
her sleeves the ovipositor just like
certain species of wasp she can insert
her eggs inside the times body leaving
them to grow and suck the life off of it
but can the egg survive in Ghidorah
strange oxygen deficient biology or will
Ghidorah just rip them off along with
parts of his body but he can regenerate
so it won't matter so do tell us what
you think of this comparison which one
takes the second place after Godzilla
anyway do like share and subscribe and
hit a notification bell for regular and
actual notifications